it's been over a week since we got our
iphone 12 and 12 pro
and after using both of them extensively
and testing them side by side
i have to say that i was wrong about
which one i think most should buy
in this video i'll tell you the real
world differences that i noticed
both the things that stood out and
surprised me and others where i was
expecting
the pro to be better but it wasn't now i
have to be honest and say that after
testing them both
it's an even tougher choice than when i
just read the spec sheet
but if you watch through this whole
video i am confident that you'll have a
much easier time choosing
which one of these is best for you let's
start out with the first area i was
surprised by and that is the displays
and display brightness
i have to say that these displays are
amazing and a good step up from last
year's screens
not only compared to the low res lcd in
the iphone 11
which was bad off axis in terms of
brightness but even against the oled in
the 11 pro
which shifted to blue if you viewed it
from the side this year's screens are
identical but apple did artificially
limit the brightness
on the iphone 12 and that really
concerned me
but i was wrong now yes you can tell a
difference if you're viewing them side
by side
but once i was out in the real world not
once did i think the display was too
dim and i wish that i was using the pro
instead
and if you're watching hdr video it
looks just as good
since both share the same 1200 nit peak
brightness
so if that was a reason you were
considering the pro don't worry about it
i also want to let you know to subscribe
if you haven't already
since we're really trying hard to hit
500k subs
before the end of the year and if you're
already a max tech fan
why not pick up one of these ultra comfy
maxtec tees to help support our efforts
thanks guys we really appreciate it now
let's talk about possibly my favorite
thing
about the regular 12 compared to the 12
pro
and that's the design when i first
unboxed the 12 i already had used the 12
pro for about 24 hours
and when i got this beautiful blue slab
of aluminum and gloss in my hand
i was shocked by how much lighter it was
even though the dimensions are exactly
the same
if you read the specs on apple's site
the difference may not seem like much
but trust me every time i picked up the
iphone 12 this last
week and a half i definitely noticed it
and even though vadim
loves the noticeably heavier weight of
the 12 pro
i much prefer the regular 12. now it
doesn't feel cheap at all like the 11
did compared to the 11 pro
maybe it's because the bezels are now
the same between them and maybe it's
because of the flat sides
that make it feel a lot more solid now
if you are holding your phone out for a
long time
like i often do when i'm watching videos
hanging out with my kids
you definitely can start to feel the
difference comfort wise and not only
because of the extra weight also because
the square edges are much sharper this
year compared to the curved edges before
and because of that they kind of dig
into your hand after a while
and it's much more noticeable with the
heavier weight pushing
against your hand compared to the
lighter 12. along with that the glass on
the back of the regular 12 is glossy
compared to matte on the 12 pro i have
to say that the pro
does look and feel more premium because
of that
and also because of its stainless steel
frame but i actually prefer the glossy
back of the 12
because it provides much more grip
overall because of all of this the
regular 12 is definitely more
comfortable in your hand even if you
have
larger hands like i do and especially if
you have smaller hands now i also want
to briefly mention the colors
the 12 has more color options and i have
to say that i
love this blue and that's weird for me
because i'm not typically a blue kind of
guy
now before i share some more differences
i want to briefly mention some
similarities that really shocked me
when the iphone 12s were announced
because last year the iphone 11s were
much more different
first off both phones waterproofing is
rated at the same
6 meters for 30 minutes and for the us
guys
out there like me that's 20 feet which
is crazy
last year the 11 pro was rated four
meters but the 11 was only
two so both having six meters of
waterproofing
is a really nice jump and these phones
are the top of the line now
with the s20 and the note 20 being rated
for just
1.5 meters now what's more relevant for
many of you
are the antennas apple didn't cheap out
and both have the very best qualcomm
x55 modems which are much faster than
the previous intel modems
but what you may not know is last year
the iphone 11 only had a 2x2 antenna
instead of a 4x4 which meant that you
would get slower speeds
and worse reception with a cheaper 11
last year but not this year both are
incredibly fast
not only for 5g but even with standard
4g lte
now one difference i didn't expect was
performance
the iphone 12 routinely scored lower in
tesla geekbench 5 than the iphone 12 pro
now i'm not certain exactly why maybe
it's apple
down clocking the a14 for the 12 for
some reason
or maybe it's just because the iphone 12
has four gigabytes of ram instead of six
in the iphone 12 pro
and this is where we start going into
the benefits of the pro
not once did i have an issue trying to
pull up an app i was using a few hours
ago
but i did notice that happening with the
regular 12 just like it did with
my iphone 11 pro max last year which
also has 4 gigabytes of ram
this is especially the case if you have
a big app open and then you want to take
a quick photo since the camera app uses
a lot of ram
and can be frustrating if whatever you
were doing didn't get saved and it got
closed
if you're somebody that gets annoyed
with this on your current phone
then definitely get the pro but as far
as performance
everywhere else like the ui smoothness
app launching and gaming
i couldn't tell the difference on the
plus side it did seem like the regular
12 was a little bit better as far as
battery life than the 12 pro
maybe because the screen was running
slightly dimmer and the cpus might be
clocked a little bit slower and also
there's less ram to power
and now let's talk about the big
difference the cameras
and how much that will matter to you the
most
obvious difference is that the regular
12 lacks a telephoto camera
but it keeps the ultra ride which i
think is the smarter choice if you're
just gonna have two
because you can always crop into a photo
but of course you can't crop out so how
much does this matter in the real world
well i definitely found myself missing
the extra camera on a number of
occasions
and not only for zoom shots we had a
rabbit run into our yard and i tried to
zoom in with the 12 and i can only zoom
in five times
so he was still small in the frame then
i ran to find
the 12 pro and with that i can zoom in
10 times
here's both side by side with the crop
you guys let me know what you think of
the difference in quality down below now
the same thing goes for
video but here the 12 can zoom in even
less
i think for video it matters even more
because as soon as you zoom in you no
longer have 4k
video not only that but for video i am
much more tempted to zoom
because that 50 millimeter lens is much
more natural for video shooting if
you're gonna do a lot of video
especially
recording yourself like i am right now
you definitely want that 50 millimeter
lens
because zooming in just two times ruins
the quality of video
but this is the kind of perspective you
want when you're shooting things
like this now other than zoom the camera
quality is almost identical
but there are a couple more things that
stand out
the first thing is that with the 12 you
can't do telephoto portraits you have to
shoot the wide portraits which the pro
he could do both
and that means if you want that same 50
millimeter perspective that
is really common with portraits you have
to crop in afterwards
which ruins the quality now along with
that
i was shocked by the quality of
nighttime portraits with the iphone 12
pro
it blew away the 11 pro max and when i
went to take one with the regular 12
unfortunately i couldn't and that's
because it lacks
the lidar sensor of the 12 pro to me
this is a deal breaker because i love
taking these kinds of shots
when i'm out in the evenings and the 12
just won't do it and in many cases
it won't even take a portrait shot if
it's dark enough and if it does it
doesn't look
great which this one looks awesome now
lighter also helps for ar
but i rarely use that and you can also
scan objects with it as well
along with that it also helps for
autofocus at night
which does make a difference for me now
surprisingly i have to say that the 12
focuses
really well better than i expected even
though it doesn't have lidar
focus is much better than the 11 pro
there's one more difference
with the 12 pro and that's the ability
to shoot dolby vision hdr at up to
frames per second instead of 30 with the
iphone 12
which is really nice now personally if i
wanted to shoot video with an iphone i
would
absolutely get the 12 pro even just for
the video capabilities alone
and now let's talk about prices right
out of the bat there is a 200
difference but if you want to buy an
unlocked iphone 12
that will cost you 30 dollars more then
we have the difference in storage
64 gigabytes compared to 128. personally
i feel like in 2020 128 gigabytes is a
sweet spot if you regularly take photos
and especially if you want to shoot
videos thankfully apple lets you upgrade
the 12 for 50
more but that also means that the
difference between the two could be as
low as 120 dollars for that price
difference
it's really tough not to buy the pro
especially if you're going to keep it
for many years
now if you don't take a lot of photos
and video and you want to have a more
comfortable phone and you like the
colors
then go for the 12. but unlike what i
thought
just a week ago i think that most people
should spend the extra money on the pro
because you get a lot more bang for the
buck with this device
you guys let me know your thoughts down
in the comment section below
and if you guys want to see our full
crazy review
on the 12 pro that vadim did it's right
over there if you want to see the review
on the 12 that will be out this week
click that circle above to subscribe so
you guys don't miss out on it
thank you guys for watching this has
been max and i will see you in the next
[Music]
video